being a lifelong new yorker
he not only has never he's never
gotten his driver's license that's a
very common thing you might see here
never got a driver's license i don't
even know if he knows how to drive
license or not but he's also hoping he
can make it his whole life without ever
getting a driver's license
so everyone please welcome drop to the
stage
hi everyone i'm dave robinson and i'm
really excited to talk about the ydr
package i'm going to share my screen now
this is a package that fits into the
tidy verse to do pairwise correlations
clustering and dimensionality reduction
all within the tidy verse
so the tidiverse i really love it it
makes a lot of data
is very fluid a lot of packages that
work together
and kind of um serve a lot of purposes
and kind of all fit
in together into a very tidy flow take
an example from one of my favorite
simple data sets the gap minder data set
of country statistics
where each row is one observation of one
country
in one year
the titles offers a lot of tools for
working with a data set like that
i could say group by year and find the
average
life expectancy so the um and uh that
would be two steps within the
the dpr flow and what i love about that
is i could pipe it right into a gigi
plot
and create a graph of the average life
expectancy per year
even within one flow i can do more
complicated operations
i could instead ask a question like find
the slope of increasing life expectancy
by country
combining the tidy versus tools of deep
play r tidy r
and broom so uh combining these tools
together into one flow we can answer
increasingly complex questions
of our data all using the tie detect
without a tidy verse
until we get to a step something like
how is each country's life expectancy
correlated with each other something i
find frustrating about a question like
that
is you sometimes have to step outside
the tidy verse to answer it
to start working with matrices then
re-tidying those matrices
and it takes you out of the flow of an
analysis so that's where the ydr
package comes in the ydr package
turns an operation like what is the
correlation between each country's life
expenses with each other
into one step with a pairwise core
function
so a pairwise course saying we're
comparing countries
linking them by year and then uh doing
the correlation of life expectancy
and also say we want to sort the outcome
in descending order we get to find out
we get to find out in one step how every
country is correlated with each other
in this case we learn about some of the
top most correlated countries like
senegal and morocco
who have highly correlated life
expectancies over time
so i'll talk about how the pairwise
chords is one example of the many
pairwise
operators that ydr provides
so d play r is really well suited for
aggregate with aggregate within
groups we say within each country i want
to know something say the average life
expectancy
so it takes this table that has several
observations for every country
aggregates each of them into one
observation
that's a group buy and summarize pattern
it's sometimes been called a split apply
uh it used to be called the split apply
recombine pattern
what pairwise operations do is instead
compare
each pair of every pair of items so
instead of ending up
with one observation for each countries
of each of the four countries in this
example
we end up with 12 observations one for
every combination
of one country and another so every
pairwise operation
is going to be really useful for taking
that one country column and finding
every possible pair of it
and then performing some useful
calculation on top of it
how does that work well the correlations
in r are traditionally done in matrices
this is actually the same uh data set
that thomas was just sharing
of penguins and their bill and flipper
lens and typically we use a function
like
core that takes a matrix and turns it
into a different matrix a matrix of
correlations
so this is the way that i would
typically have to do a correlation
and i don't like it because really when
i work with any data format
it's not a table i'm pretty much
immediately like nope
so i like to wrap all the operations of
working with that matrix
into a function if we didn't have y dr
the steps for performing the pairwise
correlation
would look something like this so it's
really a lot more steps more importantly
it's a very specific pattern
there's a step where we widen the data
in this case i'm using
uh tidyr's pivot wider function
so we need to turn this a tidy table
into a wide data set then we
operate on it using a matrix operation
in this case the core function
and finally we re-tidy it because now
that we've done the calculation we're
interested in
the correlation we need to uh to turn it
into a tidy table
together this widen operate and re-tidy
operation appears
in a lot of places i'm going to show a
couple more examples
it starts with a tidy table we widen it
into an
item by feature matrix we perform some
operation on it
that ends up finding say every
comparison between item one and item two
turn into a square matrix and then we
re-tidy it
so what's great about these pairwise
core functions and their
siblings is that the input is tidy and
the
output is tidy all the steps in the
middle where you're working with
matrices
are contained within that one function
it also takes a takes advantage of a
couple other implementation details
including that it works with sparse
matrices meaning it's very performant
so give another example of using
pairwise functions
what is on in on united nations voting
data if you joined my workshop on
thursday we actually really got to know
this data set very well
during that workshop so it's providing
the cram package un
votes and what it has is a row for each
vote of a country in the united nations
generally as general assembly
so here we see for example um each each
country has
one vote saying it voted yes it voted
abstain
or it voted no on that roll call so
in this the data set one is a yes zero
is absent
negative one is a no the feature that we
want to link together
is the roll call id the rcid and that's
that's saying well on this first
resolution the um
uh the united states canada cuba haiti
uh each voted on it
canada among them voted no
so there's 733 000 observations here
uh each representing one pair of a
country
and a year so the goal that we have
is to figure out what countries agree or
disagree with each other
so yeah i'm actually interested in
finding out how much does the united
states agree with canada
how much does the united states agree
with cuba how much united states agree
with haiti
that would be very difficult within a
typical tidy flow because it's a
pairwise operation
not an aggregation by groups but with
pairwise core
it becomes very easy
so here in one step we're saying pair i
want the
correlation of countries linked by their
res by their roll call id
and examine the correlation of the vote
element the one
zero negative one representation of did
they vote yes did they vote no
and with that we're finding piercing
correlations between
each country in terms of their votes we
find out that slovakia and the czech
republic
almost always vote together they're
correla they're the most correlated pair
of countries in the united nations we
find out that lithuania and estonia
lafayette lithuania germany and
liechtenstein all tend to vote together
they're among the most correlated
pairs of voters in the united nations
general assembly
so in one step we got from 733 000
observations
of a country and a vote down to 38
000 pairs of countries finding out their
correlations
what i love about having these this
correlation output in a tidy format
is it makes it very easy to perform
additional transformations or
visualizations
on top of it using tidyburst tools
so in this case i said let's do the
pairwise correlation of countries then
filter just
down for the united states so what
countries the united states most
correlated with well it looks like it's
the united kingdom canada
israel netherlands luxembourg and so on
this can easily with a couple more steps
of digi plot 2
can be turned to a visualization i can
use dplyr's filter
top n to discover what are the 30
largest correlations in either direction
with the united states then i can
visualize that reordering the um the
output
and discover that the um and create
visualization of the kind of political
spectrum
of countries in the world in terms of
how much do they tend to agree
or disagree with the united states in
the united nations general assembly
voting
so we can even take this a little bit
further rather than filtering for one
country
i could pick four countries like uganda
india canada and mexico
and use uh gigi plot two's faceting
to compare them so here we can uh with a
couple of steps discover
uh the countries that uh canada is most
correlated with india's
most correlated with uganda is most
correlated with and show them in one
visualization
so i really like about this is it shows
how ydr is one of a couple of tidy tools
we put together
followed by some deep player
transformations to select the country
the
observations we're interested in and
then some gg plot 2
to create our visualization the step of
finding the correlations
has been fit into our tidy workflow
let me show you a second example of
using uh using ydr in particular
pairwise correlations
and that's word co-occurrence so there's
a data set of
hacker news titles it can be retrieved
from google
bigquery i adapted this code only very
slightly and data set only slightly
from a blog post on topic models by
julia silvie
so this is a data set of the website
hacker news where uh
where people in the tech community and
um and other communities
post links to news articles and then
they um
and i took a hundred thousand articles
from the last two years
so if you've worked with text of text
database before
you might have used the tidy text
package um developed by julia silvia and
myself
and this includes the unness token
function as well as a couple of other
useful tools
for tokenizing these titles and
processing a little bit so they can be
worked with with tidy tools
so first i might use a tiny text package
to tokenize this
to turn it into one row per post
per word i also do a bit more to filter
for only common words
so once i've got data in the tidy text
format
ydr becomes very useful i can i can look
at pairwise correlations of
words so here i'm taking the the the
higher text days of words and saying
what pairs of words
most often co-occur in the same posts
something to notice here is i'm not
correlating any
value that's in the data set there's not
some number in the data set
that i want to say is it positively or
negatively correlated
rather i'm calculating the phi
coefficient the piercing correlation
on binary data this represents when the
word machine
appears in a title how much more likely
than it than usual is the word learning
to appear as well
or social with media this shows that
highest pairings of wor
of correlated words include machine and
learning social and media
neural and networks that is typical by
grams things that are
words that appear to uh together so
pairwise chord
isn't just for computing correlations on
a numeric vectors it
can also be used for co-occurrence uh
correlations just like i did with
countries i could
investigate one single word i could say
what words most co-occur
uh was disproportionately co-occur with
the word data
turns out it's science but also personal
data or data scientists or data analysis
or data privacy so we get a sense of
some of the clusters the word data
might appear with them
something that's great about pairwise
co-occurrences
is they can be fed into the tidy graph
and ggraf
packages to create a network plot so
this is
on a tour to another part of the tidy
verse where i said we're
creating tidying networks ggraf people
haven't used it
uh tidy grab is a package for uh working
with
grap with uh graph objects nodes and
vertices very sim
and edges very similar to how you'd work
with d player
and ggraf creates networks within the
grammar of graphics so very similar to
how you create them with ggplot2
so in just a couple of steps we were
able i was able to
create this network of word uh of word
associations
within hacker news titles this gives a
sense of some of the topics
that hacker news might cover we see a
giant cluster centered around things
like apple
ios javascript library development
application that seems to represent
web development we see another one a
cluster that uh
kind of linked to it by the facebook
node that might represent politics
including ones like
coronavirus or um twitter
pandemic climate and we see little
clusters for things like machine
learning and data
science we see machine learning deep
network all linked together
so pairwise co-occurrences fit really
well
with with um with network plots and the
tidy graph and ggraf packages
pairwise core is one of only is only one
of uh
several pairwise operations provided in
ydr you can also perform pairwise counts
just how often do these two items appear
together pairwise distances euclidean
manhattan
or you can do cosine similarity pairwise
mutual information
or burrows delta which is often used for
authorship
attribution and text data so um
these are a couple of pairwise
operations that ydr provides
pairwise operations have been around for
a while but something that's much newer
really
actually still only in the development
version of ydr is clustering
and dimensionality reduction uh so the
the why the widen operate re-tidy
pattern that i showed before
i showed it on pairwise operate on
pairwise operations
but it's very flexible there are many
situations in which your input is tidy
the middle is wide matrices and you want
your output to be tidy again
one example is k-means k-means is a
classic approach to clustering based on
picking one
within some number of k centers and then
it's an iterative algorithm that ends up
finding
the k centers that explain as much the
variation as you can
clustering is an example of a wide
operation we might have our data being
tidy
at first but we would need to widen it
turn into an item by feature matrix
then perform an operation that turns it
into an item by cluster
vector so that's an operation where you
might need to widen
perform an operation of clustering and
then re-tidy
this can be done with the brand new
widely k-means function
so widely k-means turns the data into a
matrix performs k-means clustering on it
and
then re-um and then re-tidies it
so if i took that gap-minder data from
earlier showing life expectancy
of each country over time and i said i
want to cluster
uh countries by their life expectancy
over time i could do that in one step
here and get a country by cluster matrix
that's part of me a country by cluster
um
cable what's great about having
the input and output be tidy is it means
it's easy to say
visualize our six clusters here i
cluster the six countries based on their
life expectancy over time and then i
join it back into the data
and visualize it showing the life exp
the
uh life expectancy trends within each of
the clusters
we see say that cluster two tend to be a
very high
um one of the highest life expectancy
groups of of countries
maybe cluster one was a very fast
growing cluster of countries
and there's other ones like uh clusters
like f crosser five and cluster three
represent countries where it started at
a lower point and might have
trended downward at various times so why
the k means let's do that all within a
tidy framework
there are three widely functions
in the development version of ydr widely
k-means
widely h-cost and widely a spd that that
was written around
svd is for a dimensionality reduction
for
singular value decomposition so i'm
going to show an example
of of combining
dimensionality reduction and k-means
clustering
i showed a couple matrix operations
earlier but sometimes you want to chain
multiple matrix operations together
you start from an extremely high
dimensionality matrix
you reduce it through singular value
decomposition a dimensionality reduction
operation
and then you perform say k-means
clustering on
the the reduced dimension space so it's
two
steps of um of matrix operations
you can do that with two widely
operations in a row
we start from a tidy one row per country
per vote
data set we perform widely svd to reduce
the dimensionality down to 16 dimensions
we produce we perform widely k means
to turn it into a into just uh six
clusters
so from that we can then get a clustered
data set performed on the reduced
dimensionality
space what i love about that is we can
then bring it into ggplot2 and the maps
package
uh with just a little bit of adjustment
to visualize our voting
blocs so i've i've now clustered the
united nations countries
based on a reduced dimensionality space
and then said they tend to fit into
these voting blocs
we can see for example there's a latin
america block in green and africa and
southeast asia block in in um
uh brown uh looks like western powers
australia and canada fit in in blue
these are groups of countries that all
tend to vote together
and just a couple steps we get to widely
we get to
cluster them and then turn them into a
map all using our set of pi diverse
tools
so in conclusion i think a really
important part of the tidy verse
philosophy comes from
a 20th century computer scientist hal
abelson
said no matter how complex and polished
the individual operations are
it is often the quality of the glue that
most directly determines the power of
the system
so a lot of power for the tidy verse
comes from this really fluid glue and
with it and what the pairwise operations
do is provide a very natural glue from
go
for going from a tiny data set to a
matrix
and then back again by turning these
wide operations into atomic
actions instead of something that takes
you out of the flow of your analysis and
you have to do some processing
then reprocessing you can do a lot with
just a little code
here the four examples we showed today
looking at the what countries most
agreed with four countries
clustering and turning words into a
network clustering and then
visualizing the trends in with of um of
life expectancy
and creating a map of similar voting
behavior each of these can be done
without a lot of code
because we've um we've turned these cl
wide operations in an atomic action so
i'm really excited to share
uh and and promote this wide ydr package
to the world thank you
thank you drob i think a lot of us are
going to get a lot of good use out of
that package i already took a bunch of
notes
i have a project i'm doing i'm going to
use like two of your functions already
for that project
so thank you very much for that great
timing of putting out this package
you